Mike was having a bad day.
At breakfast, he tripped over Tiger's bowl.
Cat food spilled everywhere.
I'll clean up, clumsy.
teased his older sister.
You need to get the bus.
Thanks!
called Mike.
At the school library, Mike checked out eight shark books.
THUMP THUMP fell the books.
He couldn't carry them all.
Need help?
asked Pam.
I only have two books.
Sure!
said Mike.
Thanks, Pam!
Pam carried some of his books back to class.
Time to frost cookies for the fall festival this afternoon.
said Ms. Platt.
Take out your frosting.
Uh-oh.
said Mike.
My frosting is at home.
You can use some of mine.
said José.
I have a lot.
Mike smiled.
Thanks, José.
The fall festival was here.
Mike was carving a pumpkin, when SPLASH.
His elbow bumped his orange punch.
Now you look like a pumpkin.
joked Dave.
I'll get my soccer shirt.
Dave said.
You can wear it.
Great!
said Mike.
Thanks, Dave.
That night, Mike told his mom all that went wrong that day.
But he also told her how nice everyone had been.
Just then, Mike heard a CRASH!
His sister tripped over Tiger's bowl.
Need help, clumsy?
laughed Mike, as he came down the stairs.
Thanks.
said his sleepy sister.